picture being the head coach of a
division one program at age 23 and then
you win the NCAA National Title in your
first year as the head coach the year
after graduating from the same school
where you won three national titles as a
player meet Aaron Matson the head coach
of UNCC field hockey and the most
decorated player in the program's
history last year when Aaron Matson was
still playing she went into the uncc's
athletic director's office and asked him
to consider making her the head coach of
the program The Following Season he
looked at this then 22-year-old who was
in the middle of her final season with
zero coaching experience but also a
22-year-old who was acc's all-time
leader in points and goals was the
youngest player to ever join the US
national team at age 16 and got the
school multiple National and conference
championships and he told her to just go
win another one and he'd consider it so
she did and now UNC athletic director
Bubba Cunningham is looking at his now
23-year-old head coach holding yet
another national championship trophy
definitely glad that he gave her a shot